This lecture is a continued discussion
of.
Discriminative classifiers for text
categorization.
So in this lecture will introduce yet
another discriminative classifier
called a support vector machine or VM,
which is a very popular classification
method, and there has been also shown
to be effective for text
categorization.
So to introduce this classifier, let's
also think about the simple case of two
categories and we have two public
categories, season one and Season 2
here.
An we want to classify documents into
these two categories and we're going to
represent again a document by a feature
vector X here.
Now the idea of this classifier is do
design.
Also a linear separator.
Here that you see and it's very similar
to what you have seen or just for
logistic regression.
And we're going to also say that if the
sign of this function value is
positive, then we're going to say the
object is in Category 1.
Otherwise, we're going to say it's in
Category 2, so that makes 0 value.
The decision boundary between two
categories.
So in general in high dimensional space
such a zero point corresponds to a
hyperplane.
I show you a simple case of two
dimensional space with just X1 and X2.
In this case this corresponds to a line
that you can see here.
So this is.
A line defined by just three parameters
here beta0
beta
2.
Now this line.
Is the heading in this direction, so it
shows that as we increase X1, X2
will also increase.
So know that beta1 and beta2
have different signs or one is negative
and there is positive.
I so let's just assume that beta one is
negative and beta two is positive.
Now it's interesting to examine then
the data instances on the two sides of
this line, so here that there are
incidences are visualized as circles
for one class and diamonds for the
other class.
Now one question is to take a point
like this one and to ask the question
what's the value of this expression or
this classifier for this data point.
So what do you think?
Basically working to evaluate its value
by using this function.
And as we said, if this value is
positive we're gonna say this is in
category one, and if it's negative it's
going to be in category Two.
Intuitively, this line separates these
two categories, so we expect the points
on one side would be positive and
points on the other side would be
negative.
Or the question is under the assumption
that I just mentioned, let's examine a
particular point like this one.
So what do you think is the sign of
this expression?
To examine the sign, we can simply look
at this expression.
Here we can compare this with, let's
say, value on the line.
Let's say compare this with this point.
They have identical X one, but then one
has a higher value for its too.
Now let's look at the sign of the
coefficient for X2, where we know this
is a positive.
So what that means is that the F value
for this point should be higher than
the F value for this point on the line.
That means this will be positive,
right?
So we know in general for all the
points on this side, the.
Functions about it would be positive.
And you can also verify all the points
on this side would be negative, and so
this is how this kind of linear
classifier or linear separator can then
separate the points in the two
categories.
So now the natural question is, which
linear separate is the best?
Now I've again she want lying here that
can separate the two classes.
And this line, of course, is determined
by the vector beta, the coefficients,
different coefficient will give us a
different line.
So we could imagine there are other
lines that can do the same job.
So gamma, for example, could give us
another line that can also separate
these instances.
And of course there are also lines that
won't separate them, and those are bad
lines.
But the question is when we have
multiple lines that can separate the
both clauses, which line is the best?
In fact, you can imagine there are many
different ways of choosing the line.
So the logistical regression classifier
that you have seen earlier actually
uses some criteria to determine where
this line should be, and it's a linear
separate as well and uses a conditional
likelihood on the training data to
determine which line is the best.
But in this VM, we're going to look at
another criteria for determining which
lines best and this time the criteria
is more tide to the classification
error.
As you will see.
So the basic idea is to choose the
separator.
To maximize the margin.
So what is the margin?
Well, I choose.
So I've shown some daughter lines here
to indicate the boundaries of those
data points in.
In each class and the margin is simply
the distance between the line, the
separator and the closest points from
each class.
So you can see the margin of this side
is as I've shown here.
And you can also define the margin on
the other side.
And in order for the separate to
maximizing the margin, it has to be
kind of in the middle of the two
boundaries, and you don't want this
separator to be very close to one side.
And then that inducing intuitively
makes a lot of sense.
So this is the basic idea of ecfmg.
We're going to choose a linear
separator to maximize the margin.
Now on this slide I've also changed the
notation so that I'm not going to use
beta.
Didn't know the parameters and, but
instead I'm going to use W, although W
was used to denote the words before.
So don't be confused here.
W here is actually wait set of weights.
And.
So I'm also using locates be to denote
beta zero, the bias constant.
And there are instances do represented
as X.
And I also use the vector form of
multiplication here.
So we see transpose of W vector
multiplied by the feature vector.
So P is a biased constant and W is a
set of weights and with one wait for
each feature we have M features and so
have aim weights and are represented as
a vector.
An similarly the data instance.
Here the text object is represented by
also a feature vector of the same
number of elements.
XI is future value.
For example word count.
I can you can verify when we multiply
these two vectors together, take the
dot product that we get the same form
of the NIA separate as you have seen
before.
It's just a different way of
representing this.
Now I use this way so that it's more
consistent with what notations people
usually use when they talk about SVM.
This way you can.
Better connected the slides with some
other readings you might do.
OK.
So.
When we maximize the margins of
separate, it just means with the
boundary of.
The separate is only determined by a
few data points, and these are the data
points that we call support vectors.
So here are illustrated to support
vectors for one class and two for the
other class.
At this, porters define the margin
basically.
And you can imagine once we know which
are support vectors, then this center
separate line will be determined by
them so.
The other data points actually don't
really matter that much.
And you can see if they you change
other data points, it won't really
affect the margin, so the separate with
the stay the same mainly affected by
the support vector machines.
Sorry it's mainly affected by the
support vectors and that's why it is
called a support vector machine.
OK, so.
The next question is of course, how can
we set it up to optimize the line?
How can we actually find the line?
Or the separator.
Now this is equivalent to finding
values for W&B because they would
determine where exactly the separator
is.
So in the simplest case, the linear
osfm is just a simple optimization
problem.
So again we let's recall that our
classifier is such a linear separator
where we have weights for all the
features and the main goal is to learn
these weights W&B.
And the classifier will say X is in
category one if it's positive.
Otherwise it's going to say it's in the
other category.
So this is our assumption or setup.
So in the linear is UVM, we're going to
then seek these parameter values to
optimize the margins and then the
training error.
The training laid out would be
basically like a in other classifiers
we have a set of training points where
we know the X vector and then we also
the corresponding label, why I?
An here we define why I as two values,
but these two values are not 01 as you
have seen before, but rather negative
one and positive one and their
corresponding to these two categories
as I've shown here.
Now you might wonder why we don't
define them as zero and one, but
instead of having negative 11 and this
is purely for mathematical convenience,
as you will see in a moment.
So the goal of optimization first is to
make sure the labeling on training data
is all correct.
So that just means if Yi, the known
label, for instance XI is one we would
like this classify value to be large.
And here we just choose threshold one
here.
But if you use another threshold, you
can see you can easily affect that
constant into the parameter values B&W
to make the right hand side.
Just one.
Now, if, on the other hand, why I is
negative one that means it's in a
different class then we want this
classifier to give us a very small
value.
In fact a negative value.
And we want this value to be less than
or equal to negative one.
These are the two different instances,
different kinds of cases and how can we
combine them together now.
This is where it's convenient when we
have chosen why I as negative one for
the other category cause it turns out
that we can easily combine the two into
one constraint.
Why I multiplied by the classifier
value must be larger than or equal to
1?
An obviously when?
Why is just one you see.
This is the same as the constraint on
the left hand side.
But when Yi is negative one you also
see a new.
This is equivalent to the other
inequality, so this one actually
captures both constraints in a unified
way, and that's a convenient way of
capturing these constraints.
What's our second goal?
That's true.
Maximizing margin, right?
So we want to ensure the separate can
do well on the training data, but then,
among all the cases where we can
separate the data, we also would like
to choose the separate that has the
largest margin.
Now the margin can be shown to be
related to the magnitude of the
weights.
The sum of squares of all those
So this to have a small value for this
expression.
It means all the eyes must be small.
So we've just assume that we have a
constraint for the getting the data on
the training set to be classified
correctly.
Now we also have the objective that's
Tide to maximization of margin and this
is simply to maximize sorry to minimize
W transpose multiplied by W and we
often denote this by file W.
So now you can see this is basically
optimization problem, right?
We have some variables to optimize and
these are the weights and B and we have
some constraints.
These are linear constraints and the
objective function is a quadratic
function of the weights.
So this is a quadratic program with
linear constraints and there are
standard algorithms that are available
for solving this problem.
And once we solve, the problem, will
obtain the weights W&B and then this
would give us a well defined the
classifier, so we can then use this
classifier to classify any new texture
objects.
Now the previous formulation did not
allow any error in the classification,
but sometimes the data may not be
linearly separable.
That means they may not look as nice as
you have seen on the previous slide
where align can separate all of them.
And what would happen if we.
Allow some errors.
The principle can stay right, so we
want to minimize the training error,
but try to also maximize the margin.
But in this case we have a soft margin
because the data points may not be a
completely separate bowl.
So it turns out that we can easily
modify it as VM to accommodate this.
So what you see here is very similar to
what you have seen before, but we have
introduced the extra variables.
Cassie I an we in fact will have one
for each data instance and this is
going to model the error that will
allow for each instance.
But the optimization problem will be
very similar.
So specifically, you will see we have
added something to the optimization
problem.
First we have added some.
Some error to the constraint so that
now we allow.
Allow the classifier to make some
mistakes here, so this KCI is allowed
error if we set KCI to 0, then we go
back to the original constraint.
We want every instance we classified
accurately, but if we allow this to be.
Zero, then we allow some errors here.
In fact, the one CI is very large.
The error can be very, very large, so
naturally we don't want this to happen.
So we want to then also minimize this
CI.
So Cassie, I needs to be minimized in
order to control the error.
And so as a result in the objective
function we also add more to the
original 1, which is only an by
basically ensuring that we're going to
not only minimize the weights, but also
minimize the errors as you see here, we
simply take a sum over all the
instances.
Each one has a CI to model the error
allowed for that instance an when we
combine them together, we basically
want to minimize the errors on.
All of them.
Now you see there's a parameter.
See here and that's a constant to
control the tradeoff between minimizing
the errors and maximizing the region of
the margin if C is set to zero, you can
see we go back to the original object
function where we only maximize margin.
And we don't really optimize the
training errors and then see I can be
set to a very large value to make the
constraints easy to satisfy.
That's not very good of course, so see
should be set to a non 0 value and a
positive value.
But when she is settled very, very
large value would see the objective
function will be dominated mostly by
the training errors and so the
optimization of margin will then play a
secondary role.
So if that happens, what would happen?
What would happen is then we will try
to do our best to minimize the training
errors.
But then we're not going to take care
of the margin and that affects the
generalization capacity of the
classifier for future data.
So it's also not good.
So apparently this parameter C has to
be actually set.
Carefully, and this is just like in the
case of nearest neighbor way you need
to optimize the number of neighbors.
Here you need to optimize the C and
this is the general also achievable by
doing cross validation.
Basically you look at the empirical
data to see what values should be set
to in order to optimize the
performance.
Now with this modification in the
problem, is there a quadratic program
with linear constraints, so the
optimization algorithm can be actually
applied to solve this different version
of the program?
Again, once we have obtained the
weights and the bias, then we can have
classified.
That's ready for classifying new
objects.
So that's the basic idea of Sven.
So to summarize, the text
categorisation methods we have
introduced many methods and some are
generative models, some more
discriminative methods, and these tend
to perform similarly when optimized, so
there's still no clear winner, although
each one has its pros and cons, and the
performance might also very different
data sets for different problems.
Ann
One reason is also becausw.
The feature representation is very
critical an so that these methods all
require effective feature
representation and to design effective
feature set that we need domain
knowledge and humans definitely play
important role here.
Although there are new machine learning
methods like representation learning
that can help with learning features.
An another common scene is that they
might be.
Be performing similarly on the data set
but with different mistakes and so
their performance might be similar, but
then the mistakes that make might be
different, so that means it's useful to
compare different methods for
particular problem and then maybe
combine multiple methods 'cause this
can improve the robustness and they
want to make the same mistakes so.
And symbol approaches that would
combine different methods and tend to
be more robust and can be useful in
practice.
Most techniques that we introduce the
use supervised machine learning and
which is a very general method.
So that means these methods can be
actually applied to any text
categorization problem as long as we
have humans to help annotate some
training data set and design features,
then supervised machine learning an all
these classifiers can be easily applied
to those.
Problems to solve the categorization
problem.
To allow us to characterize content of
text concisely with categories or the
predictor, some properties of real
world variables that are associated
with text data.
The computers of course here are trying
to optimize the combinations of the
features provided by human an.
As I say that there are many different
ways of combining them and they also
optimize different objects and
functions.
But in order to achieve good
performance, they all require effective
features and also plenty of training
data.
So as a general rule, and if you can
improve the feature representation an
and then provide more training data,
then you can generate do better.
So performance is often much more
affected by the effectiveness of
features and then by the choice of
specific classifiers.
So feature design tends to be more
important than the choice of specific
classifier.
So how do we design effective features?
Well, unfortunately this is very
application specific, so there's no
really much general thing to say here.
But
We can.
And do some analysis of the
categorization problem and try to
understand the what kind of features
might help us distinguish categories,
and in general we can use a lot of
domain knowledge to help us design
features.
An another way to figure out effective
features is to do error analysis on the
categorisation results.
You could, for example, look at the
which category tends to be confused
with each other categories and you can
use a confusion matrix to examine the
errors systematically across
categories, and then you can look into
specific instances to see why the
mistake has been made and what features
can prevent the.
This can allow you to obtain.
Insights for design new features.
So error analysis very important in
general, and that's where you can get
the insights about your specific
problem.
And then finally we can leverage some
machine learning techniques.
So for example, feature selection is a
technique that we haven't really talked
about, but it's very important and it
has to do with trying to select the
most useful features before you
actually trainer for classifier, and
sometimes training a classifier would
also help you identify which features
have high values.
And there are also other ways to ensure
the sparsity of the model.
Meaning to recognize the weights.
So for example, the SVM actually tries
to minimize the weights on features,
but you can further for some features
to falsely use only a small number of
features.
There are also techniques for dimension
reduction, and that's to reduce the
high dimensional feature space into a
lower dimensional space.
Typical biclustering of features in
various ways, so metrics factorization
has been used to do such a job, and
this and some of the techniques are
after very similar to the topic models
that we discussed, so topic models.
LDA can actually help us reduce the
dimension of features.
Imagine the words are original feature
representation, but the representation
can be mapped to the topic space
representation.
Let's say we have K topics, so a
document cannot be represented as a
vector of justice K values
corresponding to the topics.
So we can let each topic define one
dimension.
So we have K dimensional space instead
of the original high dimensional space
corresponding to words.
And this is.
Often another way to learn factor
features, especially, we could also use
the categories to supervise learning of
such low dimensional structures.
An so the original word features can be
also combined with such such latent
dimension features or low dimensional
space features to provide a
multiresolution representation, which
is often very useful.
Deep learning is a new technique that
has been developed in machine learning.
It's particularly useful for learning
representations, so different learning
refers to deep neural network.
It's another kind of classifier where
you can have intermediate features
embedded in the model so that it's
highly non linear classifier.
An some reason advance has allowed us
to train such a complex network
effectively.
Ann is the technique has been shown to
be quite effective for speech
recognition, computer vision and
recently it has been applied through
text as well.
It has shown some promise and one
important advantage of this approach in
relationship with the feature design is
that they can learn intermediate
representations or compound features
automatically, and this is very
valuable for learning effective
representation for text localization.
Although in Texas domain cause words
are excellent representation of text
content because these are.
Humans invention for communication and
they are generous sufficient for
representing content for many tasks.
If there's a need for some new
representation, people would have
invented a new words and new World.
So because of this reason, the value of
deep learning for text processing tends
to be lower than for computer vision
and speech recognition, where there
aren't corresponding wedding design.
The words.
As features.
But deep learning is still very
promising for learning effective
features, especially for complicated
tasks like a sentiment analysis, and
has been shown to be effective because
it can provide replenishing that goes
beyond bag of words.
Regarding the training examples, it's
generally hard to get a lot of training
examples because it involves human
labor.
But there are also some ways to help
with this, so one is to assume some low
quality training examples can also be
used so those can be called a pseudo
training examples.
For example, if you take a reviews from
the Internet, they might have overall
ratings.
So to train a sentiment categorizer
meaning we want to distinguish positive
from negative opinions and categorize
reviews into these two categories then.
We could assume five star reviews are
all positive training examples.
OnStar negative but of course sometimes
in five star reviews.
We also mention negative opinions so
that rain example is not all of that
high quality, but they can still be
useful.
Another idea is really exploit unable
data and there are techniques called a
semi supervised machine learning
techniques that can allow you to
combine label data with unlabeled data.
So in our case actually it's easy to
see the mixture model can be used for
both text clustering and
categorisation, so even imagine if you
have a lot of unable text data for
categorization then you can actually do
clustering on these text data to learn
categories.
And then try to somehow align these
categories with the categories defined
by the training data where we already
know which documents are in which
category.
So you can in fact use the EM algorithm
to actually combine both.
That would allow you essentially to
also pick up a useful words in the
unlabeled data.
You can think of this in another way.
Basically, we can use, let's say a
naive Bayes classifier to classify all
the unlabeled text documents.
And then we're going to assume the high
confidence classification results, or
actually reliable.
Then you certainly have more training
data.
The cause from the unlabeled data we
some are labeled as category ones and
more labeled as category two.
Although the label is not completely
reliable.
But then they can still be useful.
So let's assume they are actually
training label examples and then we
combine them with the true training
examples.
To improve categorization method and so
this idea is very powerful and when the
enable data and training data are very
different and we might need to use
other advanced machine learning
techniques called domain adaptation or
transfer learning, this is when we can
borrow some training examples from a
related problem that may be different
or from a categorisation task that.
That involves data that follow very
different distributions from what we
are working on.
But basically when the two domains are
very different than we need to be
careful not to overfit the training
domain, but yet we can still want to
use some signals from the related
training data.
So for example, training categorisation
on news might not give you an
immediately effective classifier for
classifying topics in tweets, but you
can still learn something from news to
help categorizing tweets, so there are
machine learning techniques that can
help you.
Do that effectively.
Here's a suggestion reading an where
you can find more details about some of
the methods that we have covered.